y penas de cárcel de 5 a 20 años más
varias cadenas perpetuas son las que
solicitó esta tarde el ministerio
público francés después de tres días de
requisitorio en el proceso por los
atentados del 13 de noviembre del 2015
tres días excepcionales como lo ha sido
este proceso que ya lleva nueve meses
obviamente una de las perpetuas es para
salas de slam el único sobreviviente de
los comandos del 13 de noviembre otra
perpetua para mohamed abril y su amigo
de la infancia que también participó en
el atentado de bruselas y perpetua
también para varios logistas y para
aquellos que se comprobó pertenecían a
la célula yihadista la abogada del
ministerio público eran tres pero hoy la
que habló fue la abogada ella explicó
que las penas iban a ser duras porque
son proporcionales al daño cometido y
porque en francia el terrorismo es de
los crímenes más duramente penados
también explicó la abogada al ministerio
público que si ellos eran hoy culpados
era porque habían adherido a una
ideología y que sigue en la cárcel no es
el lugar para que una persona
desenganche de una ideología es la única
solución socialmente aceptable para
proteger a la sociedad y explicó también
que el silencio y la mentira son un
derecho dentro de un proceso y que en
este proceso todos los acusados en algún
momento hicieron uso de ese derecho se
mantuvieron fieles dijo hasta el final
recordemos que el próximo lunes
comienzan los alegatos de los abogados
de los acusados y que se espera un
veredicto para el próximo 29 de junio